[Musique]
dans le journal du dimanche marion
maréchal-le pen attaque frontalement
marine le pen mais surtout florian
philippot critiquée pour avoir proposé
de revenir sur le remboursement intégral
est illimité de l'avortement la députée
frontistes ne retient plus ses coûts
paraissent que vous leur dites ici ce
matin c'est la cour de récréation ça
suffit donc je dis à tout le monde
les électeurs ne nous pardonneront pas
alors qu'ils espèrent tant en nous nous
pardonnons pas de tomber dans des
chicanes
vous avez peur ils n'ont pas compris
parce que nous avons déjà nous pris les
risques que vous avez pris des risques
pour beaucoup je sais que certains ont
pu dépression on tue même plus que ça
certains ont été punis étaient rares je
sais ça
vous alliez le faire gagner parce que
c'est notre public
[Applaudissements]
c'est un peu l'archétype classique de
l'image qu'on veut donner du politique
qui hurlent et qui va remporter des
suffrages comme ça je renverrai bien aux
images du loup de wall street un très
beau film de martin scorsese
il ya certes un certain écho avec ces
images pas seulement dans la forme mais
aussi dans le fond quelqu'un qui dit aux
traders avec qui il travaille je vais
vous gagnez de l'argent c'est un petit
peu sale projet d' emmanuel macron je
pense pour la jeunesse de ce pays
car comme disait la chanson je suis
comme je suis alors à propos du fait
comme ça a donc les français me
prendront ou pas ainsi parce que je veux
être le candidat de la justice je suis
les candidats du travail quand j'ai été
ministre je ne considère pas que c'était
mes conseillers ou mon directeur de
cabinet qui était responsable de ce que
j'ai mal fait ils m'ont toujours bien
conseillé c'est la faim moi qui ai pris
parfois des mauvaises décisions parce
que j'ai eu aussi des échecs avec une
extrême droite aux portes du pouvoir et
le programme particulièrement dur de
françois fillon qui incarne une droite
rétrécit et rabougri ma responsabilité
est de créer l'unité fin de citation
êtes vous candidat à la primaire de la
gauche
oui je ne pars pas dans cette primaire
uniquement même pour gagner la primaire
je veux que nous puissions gagner la
présidentielle
merci à vous président merci d'avoir été
là
la toile s'est bien amusé ce week end en
regardant emmanuel macron hurler à la
fin de son meeting parisien
une métamorphose pour le candidat à
l'élection présidentielle parodier en
chanteur de métal le dernier rappel
je pense simplement que quand on est
devant un micro il faut arriver à poser
sa voix sur les paroisses et la bourre
sur la forme affaires d'autrui si sa
valeur et faire celle ni patrick bruel
ni johnny hallyday après deux ans loin
de la vie politique française
vincent peillon se lance dans la
bataille avec l objectif dit-il de
rassembler autour de son nom comme un
symbole il s'est rendu dans un centre
d'hébergement parisien
je veux rendre hommage cette france
qu'on ne voit pas beaucoup celle des
bénévoles celle des travailleurs sociaux
celle aussi des professeurs des écoles
qui accueillent ces enfants d'étrangers
que madame le pen veut mettre dehors
bienvenue chez un patient maintenant de
savoir sur le fond ce qui motive vincent
peillon
je n'ai pas susciter cette candidature
vous avez pays il faut arrêter de penser
comme s'il y avait des gens qui sont des
marionnettes et d'autres qui sont d'une
barre youn et east vous demandez à ces
informations du canard enchaîné selon
lesquelles vase un dîner avec marisol
touraine maîtrise et d'acision avec
martine aubry document est radicalement
fausses marques je n'ai comme adversaire
que la droite dure de monsieur fillion
et l'extrême droite le député eduardo
riant sippel et patrick mennucci lui ont
déjà apporté leur soutien anne hidalgo
de son côté regarderai cette candidature
d'un bon oeil avait été très très bon
dans son émission
de france 2 et je vois là je le félicite
mais je pense qu'il nous manquait cette
ligne sociale-démocrate et et que
vincent peillon incarne les stratégies
d'empêchement ça m'intéresse pas
beaucoup pour être très honnête
la question que je vois apparaître entre
manuel valls et vincent peillon c'est
que ce sont finalement les deux frères
du hollandisme qui se disputent
l'héritage
où sont les femmes dans cette primaire
côté y en avait une
c'était marie noëlle lienemann qui était
candidate est annoncé et qui a renoncé
pas parce qu'elle a eu peur parce
qu'elle a renoncé par sens des
responsabilités si lagarde est attendue
devant la cour de justice de la
république dans le cadre de la sphère
bernard tapie et les 400 millions
d'euros versés dont litige qui
l'opposait au crédit lyonnais quand je
n'ai plus rien à prouver
comme vous l'avez dit j'ai occupé les
plus grands ministères régaliens
si jal j c'est parce que il me paraît
indispensable de ne jamais baisser les
bras
accusé de vouloir démanteler la sécurité
sociale françois fillon sort de son
silence et riposte dans une tribune que
publie le figaro
au lieu de regarder les faits mes
détracteurs me soupçonne de vouloir
privatiser l'assurance maladie et
diminuer les remboursements
c'est évidemment faux est-ce qu'il est
revenu sur ce qu'il annoncé dans son
programme et non mais la ceni nous
couvrons tous les soins mais il a dit
qu'il est mon ami mais les rues il a dit
exactement la même chose tous les soirs
c'est un retour un premier recul il y en
aura d'autres sans doute françois fillon
était le candidat de l'inflexibilité il
est devenu en quelques heures on gagne à
la confusion raison que c'est un peu le
piège des primaires ou bien ils allaient
les maires la primaire à droite et après
la présidentielle il faut la gagner au
sens françois fillon se rend compte
aujourd'hui qu'il a été élu dans la
primaire de droite que la primaire de
droite c'est pas la france et que
aujourd'hui tout le monde est en train
de réaliser à quel point son programme
est dangereux il y a un projet caché qui
est à peine caché si c'était celui de la
primaire on va confier de plus en plus
de responsabilités aux organismes
complémentaires et ça c'est inquiétant
quand certains dans cet hémicycle se
situe dans une perspective de des
remboursements des dépenses de santé
mon gouvernement lui agira à la sab le
mans pour renforcer le droit de nos
concitoyens à se faire soigner
oser faire un discours de politique
générale alors qu'il ne peut pas y avoir
de temps pour inscrire cette généralité
s'est joué un peu avec les institutions
dites monsieur le premier ministre aura
terminé de lire ses textos pourra
continuer
merci
le premier ministre qui entend se servir
de ces cinq mois pour essayer d'aider le
futur candidat du parti socialiste
c'était un discours électoral avant tout
la seule personnalité
même si j'ai eu avec cette personne des
désaccords sur différents sujets la
déchéance de nationalité aux houles à la
sphère le burkini la seule personnalité
qui alla l'envergure d'un homme d'état
c'est manuel valls venu de nos rangs le
débat a été mis très tôt sur les roms
pour finir sur le burqini c'est à dire
sur des questions identitaires
je n'ai pas peur de l'identité mais j'ai
une identité elle est républicaine
démocratique sociale et laïque et on
peut pas me les éloigner le président
fait un bond spectaculaire de 14 points
14 points après sa décision de ne pas se
représenter
le grand danger du favori comme vous
dites et des exemples vous appréciez
vous le sens dorment ils pensent qu'ils
ont gagné non rien n'est joué rien n'est
gagné je ne suis pas favori moi je suis
challenger dans cette élection
présidentielle premier ministre a
présenté aujourd'hui son qg de campagne
sa nouvelle équipe également dans le 3e
arrondissement de paris alors c'est vous
qui représentait le système ce dont les
français ne veulent plus donc c'est
grâce à vous qu'on peut convaincre
manuel valls qui a effectué pour un site
internet le tour du propriétaire et
affirmé que s'il voulait une campagne
sympathique dans l'esprit elle décoiffe
ray au niveau des idées vous voyez vous
n'êtes que dans cela mais plus vous êtes
dans cela plus les français ne
supportent plus le système celui qui
veut rassembler à gauche a réussi à
rallier de nombreux ministres onze
membres du gouvernement l'ont rejoint
officiellement parmi eux jean marie le
guen ou encore patrick kanner est ce
qu'il ya une mesure que qui vous
semblent intéressants va pour être
honnête avec vous un rien parce que dans
mon lycée
enfin aubervilliers les terminales de
l'année dernière ils ont fait un an sans
prof de maths et je ne vous avais pas
pensé à nous en un an vous auriez pu
être enfin peu de un prof de maths alors
chacun à ses troupes
finalement vous savez autour d'un moment
nous on a plusieurs dizaines de
parlementaires des élus locaux beaucoup
d'élus locaux alors que chacun trouve
ses soutiens sait très bien que chacun
ait ses amis c'est très bien c'est tout
à fait le jeu naturel mais en même temps
ça ne semble pas l'essentiel est en tout
cas pour mes soutiens moi je les
remercie paraissait cohérent que des
gens qui aient participé gouvernement de
manuel valls pendant les deux dernières
années soutiennent manuel valls qui
serait pas cohérent ce serait plutôt le
contraire parce qu'à ce moment là qu'est
ce qu'il faisait au gouvernement vincent
peillon ne serait pas un jour de ses
cotisations au parti socialiste depuis
trois ans il n'aurait pas payé non plus
sa quote-part d'eurodéputés la somme
s'élèverait à près de vingt mille euros
que je veux un beau débat d'idées vous
l'avez vu pas un échange de boules
puantes donc si certains sont un peu
nerveux ya plus de 20 ans je suis au
parti socialiste s'il ya des cotisations
à mettre à jour les mettra à jour comme
toujours avant l'europe
il a dû ce matin s'acquitter d'un
arriérés de cotisation au ps près de
20000 euros à chacun comme important il
a bien été dénoncé par un gentil
camarades non je ne sais pas s'ils
étaient des lancers ce que je veux
simplement dire c'est que ça permet de
rappeler à celles et ceux qui nous
regardent qu'eux on parle souvent des
élus qui s'en mettent plein les poches
les élus sont bien rémunérés mais ils
ont essayé de trail autres cotisations
qu'arnaud montebourg particulièrement
devred encore 80000 euros d'arriérés
dont près de 50000 euros au groupe ps à
l'assemblée ce soir l'attaché de presse
d'arnaud montebourg affirme que celui-ci
a déjà versé 52 1415 euros au ps local
et national
bah oui on pense pas la catégorie
financière les premières odeurs de ces
primaires socialistes sont
particulièrement décevantes puisque
gibault confirmant les boules puantes
comme ça on se demande d'où ça vient
à qui ça sert on espère que ça va
s'arrêter parce que si ça ne s'arrête
pas c'est la primaire qui en danger
pardonnez moi cette se moque on va
reprendre et qui est entendu à gauche
par un cadre dirigeant
ça la fout mal qu'est ce que vous pensez
vous du spectacle unique et données avec
celles de ça la fout mal
et moi ça me choque vous êtes bien un
jour de vos cotisations au psg au oui
non sinon pas de candidature votre
candidature fillon de la gauche non mais
jouer benoît non seulement juste benoît
hamon est ce que vous avez demandé à
françois fillon s'il voulait être le
benoît hamon je connais parfaitement les
effets pervers du 49 3 je suis très
lucide et puis j'ai appris et puis on
prend du recul dans la société de la
participation dans laquelle nous vivons
son utilisation est devenu dépassé et
elle apparaît comme brutal êtes surpris
mahjoub ben oui parce que je viens de le
dire que sa position
bah écoute et l'exercice du pouvoir et
je les fais avec le premier ministre
appelé manuel valls
il ya eu des 49 3 la proposition de
supprimer le 49-3 de la part de l'ancien
premier ministre aurait dû être précédé
une suppression du 49-3 dans les
pratiques et l'exercice du pouvoir
il ya donc une forme d'incohérence entre
les paroles et les actes
le jour on a besoin de 49,3 sur un
budget on n'a que ça à droite qui à
l'audition des budgets je propose tout
simplement qu'on puisse l'utiliser que
pour les textes budgétaires parce que
une nation a besoin d'un
budget et qu'on le supprime tel qu'il
existe aujourd'hui
moi je propose 1 49 3 citoyens c'est à
dire la possibilité pour un pour cent
des électeurs inscrits sur les listes
électorales par pétition d'obliger à ce
qu'un texte de loi
quand ils sont donc quatre cent
cinquante mille c'est ça un pour cent
des citoyens inscrits sur les listes
électorales d'objets ce qu'un texte une
loi votée à l'assemblée passe par
référendum
marc est toujours une bonne idée de
reconnaître ses fautes et ses erreurs et
moi je me réjouis que manuel valls
avance dans cette direction d'arc s'il
continue ainsi sa campagne il va bientôt
finir par me dire qu'il faut évacuer
notre dame des landes
pourquoi ne l'at il fait il va finir par
nous dire qu'il faut à redresser les
comptes de la sécurité sociale faire
baisser le chômage
au fond ils sont eux mêmes les propres
juges du bilan de son quinquennat
[Musique]